hello friends it's uh me again
your favorite person louis um you know
it's coming up on my
birthday and i'll be 58 years old
and i've been kind of depressed lady
because i was thinking about you know
way back
when i was uh from the start of when i i
remember i think my first birthday room
i was
five years old and i can remember that
uh
they kind of threw like a halfway kind
of party with me and matter of fact
two nights before that was when my that
went salather
anyway shalata had started molesting me
so so so that guilt
was even at five at five years old that
guilt was on my conscience
and i i remember i'm gonna talk about
the way i feel i remember when i was
around my family i felt
so uh i felt so so empty so afraid so
so i feel like i was the worst person in
the world i feel like i feel like
there was nobody it was nobody could
ever be as bad as me
why why was i gonna want to get cursed
for you know with this lady all over top
me and me with my with my with my nose
all between her legs
and i i never forget that [ __ ] smell
god damn
of course i like it now but back then
anyway so anyway thought we had to head
through this birthday party for me we
had this little dog a little dog named
mimi and uh the poor little dog i mean
the little dog was a thing was a little
cocker spraying whatever i remember for
some reason
well let me back up that was around
about the time
my mother and father used to get in a
lot of physical fights
and um my father would beat my mother he
would literally be my mother
and that hurt me so bad and i always
felt like
for some reason i felt like that that
was my fault because
my dad was always getting it was it was
always he was getting on my case
you know worse than the rest of the kids
i get the most weapons
i get the most cursing outs you know the
most talking to the most
[ __ ] julian and i never i never heard
that from the other
to the other children so that made me
feel i'm to the top of my feeling
so my feelings that's what i'm talking
about my birthday my feelings my
feelings were really
they were really [ __ ] up but then i
had nobody to talk to
you know and i so some of these feelings
that i locked down way
back as i was five years old even though
now i'm 58 and there's
they're they're they're they never go
away they never go away
they're still down back pack packed on
remember once i went to a drug rehab
and one guy kind of faded out he said he
said
he said louis he said who are you close
to in here you know maybe about 50
people in the room
and i couldn't bring out one person he
says he he says he's you
something you did as a child something
has you something has you bound
as you lock down there's something to
happen you deep deep and got your spirit
sunk down and you need to you need you
need to talk about that and pull that
[ __ ] up
you know so now that i'm like 58 years
old
this shit's starting to come up and
thank god for this youtube channel even
though it's embarrassing to help me to
talk about this [ __ ]
[ __ ] y'all it's i'm getting off of it
it's making me feel better you know what
i'm saying so hey
you know i thank god for this little
camera i'm doing this in front of
so you know um i i i oh still
at the birthday party and i remember i
remember it was my birthday party and
all the kids
all the all the bigger kids the footy
genara down the street he was a bully
tearing general
they were bullies of mine they would
beat me up and everything
and i remember that i got a tricycle i
got a little red tricycle
with a little golden wheel and i would
get out on the sidewalk and i we
we can go down and then the next day
after my birthday there was this guy
about three doors down
he had just paved his driver with his
most beautiful wife
now i know i know i know what c men and
[ __ ] like that is basically now
back then i know and it it just
seemed it just looked like the sidewalk
was so ugly we lived in a poor town and
the sidewalks had a big bump for you
right you're right just try to
turn your tricep over your ride your
bicycle you break all your damn smokes
the sirens is all [ __ ] up but this
particular driveway
was real nice and smooth so i thought i
said well i want to ride my new tricycle
on a noodle and i remember this old man
he's standing in front of the house i
guess he's standing in front of the
house
looking at his driveway like wow i did a
good job and here i go
i drove the bike dude you know how the
we usually when they when they do they
make these little laundry
they tied the lines up i drove the
tricycle right through the [ __ ] lines
and got a big circle
in that man's driveway um and i
left out i was five years old and that
man i never was forget the expression on
that man's face that man
looked at me he's like he was a white
guy he said you little [ __ ]
he grabbed me by the back of my shirt
like that well he grabbed me in that
[ __ ] trickle
he took me to the house he banged on
that door he said miss so-and-so
you said you get this goddamn [ __ ] he
just put that bicycle on my damn
on my damn concrete and if you and your
husband don't pay i'm coming out i'm
[ __ ] everybody i know i remember here
specifically saying that to my mother my
mother
oh she took me in the house dude she
woke my ass
and the thing was i felt so i'm gonna
talk about my feeling
i mean what i did was wrong but i didn't
know i
i just i didn't know the guy was i mean
the guy was standing he could have told
me i was always kind of slow
i was never snappy snappy i was you know
slow i'm still kind of like that
so the guy with the guy i mean the guy
standing there
he's looking at me was unfolding i mean
dude i was five years ago i swear i
remember like it was yesterday
he's a big big tall white guy like
donald victor like donald trump big
big ugly [ __ ] and he said here
and
and i he could have said hey man don't
don't
don't go he just watch me do it
he just didn't want but i remember my
mother wore my ass
my brother would mass my sister punked
me
and my father home he put the he put the
leather bill he put my father
told my ass up so that was from my
birthday time so that that set me off on
a collision course for the rest of my
life because
i thought i was the worst person in the
world but i bet the babysitter molested
me i [ __ ] up the men's yard
i had oh i was all the kids were i was i
was i was afraid of the kids i was
afraid all the
big the big guys liked you and i was
afraid of them so they're digging their
hands and my cake and i'm too scary i'm
too scared of them just hey man
get your hands out my cake and now i'm
gonna beat the [ __ ] but now i was like
i'm just i'm sitting like some kind of
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude and i'm just sitting
like this you know and they're tearing
up my [ __ ] cake
my mom's over there they're drinking and
they're drinking and doing everything to
grow up
and i wanna say watch your cake donald
watch watch you think now
watch your cake let's watch your cake
and i'm thinking i'm sitting there
shaking scared you guys should have they
i didn't get i didn't get a piece of the
[ __ ] cake you know
i was that was my first my first
memories of one of my first birthdays
now
the second one i can remember was
i was about oh i had to be
15 60 years old and i remember we went
to my
one of my cousins out there they stayed
in a ritzy kind of ritzy little area but
they had little white girls up and down
the street running down
and i remember oh
you guys know me i remember there was a
little white girl down the street she
used to wear these she was wearing these
little these nice little little skirts
with these little denials
she was about i guess i guess i was
about 16 she may have been about
14 or 15. and she would always come down
and they will lose
come down her little pink bite with the
little bass on the front and she comes
hey louis she come down she waving me so
you know my little thing start getting
hard for her hey check this out
would you come up in the garage so one
day i tear up in the garage
you know a lot of times i would mess
with them that one didn't work because i
went out i mean
i remember when i took her up in there
i'm getting off this [ __ ] when i took
her up in there
she said why she said why are you
closing the door you know i was a little
you know i was i was going to do
something with her you know so i
kind of pushed her up against the wall i
tried i tried to go up in her you know
and she
no no she pushed me off she ran home and
told her father oh my god
she ran over to her father they said
nothing to me
they said something to my mother
and my mother never told my father
because my father would have [ __ ]
killed me but my mother she put me in
the room
she made me take all my clothes off she
made me sit in the room with no clothes
on
for 24 hours i couldn't wear clothes for
24 hours she said
i'm going to embarrass you like you
embarrass me in front of that little
girl now you're going to sit for an
awkward eat dinner
and everything with no [ __ ] clothes
on i sure did
that happened here here's here's here's
a stroke here's a struggle
i went to they i went to arkansas we got
found in arkansas i went to arkansas i
guess i was about
this this is this is one of the stories
i've never told about because i don't
know what happened
i was about nine nine ten years old
it was around about my birthday and they
had these
chicken coops where they they fought
they fought chickens and they had this
little little barn like
in the back and you know and i was
always i was always a little sneaky
little kinky [ __ ] you know
always like i always like to know white
girls i always like them you know white
girls
i remember there's a couple of white
girls i don't know but
where i was at you don't speak to no
white girl you don't talk to no white
girl you don't wave you know white girl
you damn shoulder whistle
whenever they hit you don't wake up does
that hang your ass out there where i was
at
i'm a little kid i'm about 10 i don't
know nobody
that now i i to this day i don't know
out of out of being traumatized i don't
honestly know what i did
they took me out it was like in in in it
for like for like it was it was in the
summertime like it was like in july
sometime in the summer
they took me out all i had on was a pair
of shorts and a pair of thongs
and they tied me to a [ __ ] tree
and left me out there for two
[ __ ] days with nothing to eat and
went in and i remember that lady saying
you will never ever do what you did
again but i and to this day
i don't know what the [ __ ] i did i don't
know if i
if i was traumatized but they tied me to
a tree for two [ __ ] days it might
have been longer than two days but i
remember
i don't i don't remember i remember the
the
the the the mosquitoes and and the and
the and the bugs and the potato bugs and
the wasps whatever the little thing i
remember
the a couple of bees stung me on the
neck but i remember
i remember i remember praying you know i
said god i don't know i remember
thinking thinking bears are going to get
me
and i and i and i sometimes when i when
i think back about this i never talked
about it
because i i'm i'm i wonder if it really
happened or was i it
was to me it's so bizarre i i could have
been dreaming it
that i could have dreamed and just
thought one of one of the dreams that
i've had no but it wasn't a dream it's
something that i did with those white
girls in that barn i
but i don't know what it i did something
with those white girls and they wanted
to kill me
they wanted to kill me that was a
birthday i remember
and uh
i remember the first birthday i had i'm
trying like i remember the first break
they had when after i had my child oh
god
oh god the way i felt
i thought about even though even even
though even though
even though my my parents abused me
physically and mentally but they
financially took care of me so i was i
was
so i'm gonna hear my hair my child was i
i had given her up i
had i turned i turned i think i turned i
don't know what what age i turned i
might have turned
41 or something 41 or something like
that and i hadn't i had i
hadn't had i hadn't done anything for
her
and i if if i look back on today what
i'm depressed about because
i actually can honestly say that my poor
and my poor child
had nothing to do with me bringing her
as well because she's of my sperm and i
have a resentment against her
because i wouldn't my excuse for not
doing them for it
because well you don't want me know it
because they gave you to my sister
when we went to court
if i get honest about it we wouldn't we
i'm so everything my sister's true
but if i get honest about my way i feel
by my part i
[ __ ] up because i signed her over
because
the judge looked at me and oh god
he looked at me and he was going to give
me another chance you know he looked at
her mom and said her mom was a washout
push her to the side we [ __ ] her he said
you you sit over there
because i'm sitting there because i'm
i'm i'm so i got tears coming by
i'm sitting in a she sitter and she's
centered with her gay girlfriend she's
my girl my
daughter's mother has a gay girlfriend
and they're sitting over there almost
sexual ass and look at each other's eyes
i
think
there's everything i didn't use his
[ __ ] that night and i was gonna wonder
what's going on with my daughter
so my boy says we're sitting in the back
of the [ __ ] courthouse
and she's begging me off please let me
take care of her let me have it in the
hammer
that's okay i give up my rights i just
give up my [ __ ] rights
worst thing and the best thing in the
world i could do for her
but for me it put uh it put uh it put us
it put a sword like sinbad all the way
through my heart through the through the
front and out of the back
it was one in there it's a and paul was
in the bible talked about a thorn in his
side
i got i got one going through my heart
and there seems like there's no there's
there's the only the only way to release
the pain is to take a drink
you know so lately i haven't been
drinking and so that's why i'm depressed
because i haven't been drinking well i
ain't got no money then drinking i don't
have no income coming anymore
so i have to hustle with all these
different things to get money
when i was when i was when i was smoking
when i was high on crack all the time
well hell i could i could you know what
i did one time i wanted one time my
birthday
i broke into a house and i let me take
some you look
i ain't no i don't be breaking no house
not looking and i walked by the house
and the [ __ ] and what and this
[ __ ] door was cracked on me
well hell i looked at the crack and i
said well [ __ ] cause i was homie i was
high on that [ __ ] i needed to hit
well let me see i snuck in the house and
i'm going out from walking through the
house i'm
picking up there and i think there's a
lady and a man they're in the bed
they're both stark naked i guess they've
been screwing they're in the bed
they're laying there and i see the man's
jeans
i never they they would levi 501's they
were laying on the floor and i could see
the man wanted kind of sticking out the
back
so i looked around my house now y'all
i'm throwing them around my eyes all big
y'all and then i picked a pair of pants
and i actually pulled the water out the
pens and i opened it up and i'm
counting the [ __ ] money in there i
mean
this average person would have with any
kind of brain would have took the
[ __ ] water
and bam took the [ __ ] off i'm standing
there counting the [ __ ] money
i'm just kidding i'm gonna set the water
back down i put them in about 300
i put them out of my pocket and i'm i'm
i actually i'm in these people's
jewelry boxes and [ __ ] i'm going this
guy he had a lunch he had a really nice
langine giant a langi
loji would have watched like long as he
watched i got some fake
jewelry beads whatever the girl has and
i grabbed those and i remember i'm
walking i mean i actually went in the
universe she went in the kitchen and
they had a half of a
subway sandwich i actually took that
subway sandwich i love milk chocolate
milk and i took some messy quick
chocolate
milk and i poured it in the glass i sat
down and ate the sandwich
and drank the goddamn they're in the bed
and i i
i don't i don't know how i did that i
did that that one time
so another time i thought i could do it
oh i'm feeling i'm getting i'm getting
i'm getting there that particular time i
didn't get caught
so i guess it was about maybe three or
four months later
i wanted to try that [ __ ] again so i'm
walking around this new this
neighborhood and i know where the
mountains and i'm i'm just
pulling doors i'm checking i'm just
walking up like i'm dressing i'm just
pulling and checking doors when one of
them damn doors open
when i went i never forget i'll opened
the door
and got it it scared me and when i
opened the door
there was a lady sitting in a wheelchair
and she looked like like look just like
like like the mona lisa and i'm spooky
real spooky looking and she's sitting in
that chair
with a half and then when i saw that
lady because i know i got my hand i'm
opening it i was yeah i could
and i'm looking for you rocking in the
[ __ ] [ __ ] she didn't scream
she didn't holler and i remember being
so terrified
i couldn't [ __ ] move i was like oh
[ __ ] the big guy's gonna come out with
the bat the little boys are gonna come
around
sparky and jiggy gonna come around the
back the dogs i couldn't move
i know i stood there two or three
minutes i know i did
no not a word was saying we were just
standing there we were just [ __ ]
sitting everyone walking down the street
and i don't to this day i don't get i
know this guy
i remember walking down the street and i
remember the cops drove by
and they said hey have you seen a guy
they
they will gave me a description now this
and this guys
they were looking for a white guy
they always think it was black food they
usually saw the white people say have
you seen the black knight they said hey
have you seen a white guy about so tall
with glasses
oh no no no i know they're looking for
me oh no oh you know what it was a guy
on a red bicycle i think i did
a rick on a red bicycle oh yeah so i
kind of i got away with that one
i never did that [ __ ] [ __ ] again
so anyway um god damn
i gotta hold this [ __ ] so as time went
on i
uh i would get up i would have my
birthday my mom around my daughters my
birthday comes
and i started thinking about my daughter
so
the first i would say nine ten years of
her life i'm not lying i'm not
exaggerating
the fire department or the lapd or the
long beach pd whoever
would wake me up and i'd have a bottle
of liquor
and i would have drink until i would
literally it would the the fire
department or the paramedics
had to put that stuff that they put in
your nose to get you to wake up and one
time
one time they couldn't i i man god damn
i remember this
one time i was i was it was it was the
wiener schnitzel and i don't know like
it was real cold i could see today and i
remember the windowsill had a bathtub
like a big giant roof over it when you
get up on it when it's cold and they had
the side walls where you could you know
the wind couldn't get to you and i could
get up under there with my little jacket
and wrap up and go to sleep
i got up on it i had a fifth i had a
fear for jack daniels and i drank
i drank the fifth and i remember when i
was up under that i remember under there
and i remember the pyramid is trying to
wake me up and
it was it was like it was like it was
like my body was there
but i it was like my spirit or my spirit
was somewhere else because i remember
the pyramid said wake up wake up wake up
wake up
and they were putting the stuff in my
face and some white guy was doing
the mouth mouth-to-mouth resuscitation
and i i could hear him and i and i
was i was wanting to say hey i i
acknowledge you i'm i'm i'm alive i'm
awake
but i think i think i might have been
about two shades from being dead i think
i was too i don't know
about too shaky being dead and finally i
don't know i don't know one of the guys
one of the officers
matter of fact i can remember somebody
saying i think we're losing him
and i mean i remember i remember pulling
pulling something out of my shoulders i
ain't ready to go
i'm not i remember somebody somebody
somebody went like that and i just i
just i don't know who did it
it was somebody in another spirit if it
was one of the cop but somebody
and i just all of a sudden i woke up and
i remember the officer said
what's going on and i said i broke down
and cried i said my
brother's birthday guy he bought me some
hot dogs
what's the cop he took me home waiting
to get through my grandma's house he was
a real nice guy he really
but i mean and i told him he said well
you don't have to you know you don't
have to drink
what are you going to do differently you
know i and i keep saying i'm going to do
something different and every every
birthday i do the same thing i gotta
load it again
well one after after after after that
birthday
i felt like well you know knowing the
rehab what do we have but after every
but i feel like if this guy can care
enough about you
i said why can't i care enough about
myself that i won't i won't
stop trying to kill myself as far as
like that on my birthday
trying to drown it out and start dealing
with this [ __ ] now i still get drunk but
i get drunk and talk about it
even if i'm talking to the bus stop and
ain't nobody in the bus stop
so those are the kind of birthdays i had
no now this is not going to take much
then i'm going to talk about i'm
trying to feed them now there's chris
crittenden
crips went by and new year's went by ah
i kind of did okay but you know what i
didn't get one on christmas
i sat up in the house my friend called
me i set up in the house no tv
no radio no nothing blind's closed
lights off
i sat there like a [ __ ] zombie
feeling sorry for myself
oh poor me why do i have to be an
alcoholic
why do i have to be a crackhead why do i
have to have these molestation issues
why did i mess with the little girl
myself
you know why why why was my life so
[ __ ] up and so
so bad as a kid you know and i you know
i i i really need to come here and talk
but i just you know i really
need somebody to talk they need to get
off of that [ __ ] but that happened to me
on christmas
and then when they came over when they
came over new year's and everybody was
outside my apartment they were they were
cooking
and celebrating and [ __ ] and
understanding i had a father fight
at a fifth of a cardinal about 20 in a
rock and i'm sitting there
and i'm thinking you know and and and i
i remember saying
i'm gonna do this [ __ ] and i'm gonna
stop [ __ ] with this [ __ ] you know
what i
and i drank that i mean i remember the
jd made me so sick and the cocaine i
bought was fake
i said well maybe god gave me a sign you
know what i threw all this [ __ ] in the
trash you know
sweat off i never ever ever ever doing
that [ __ ] again with god damn it two
days later
i had another fifth and another goddamn
rock so i said to myself here my stupid
ass
go again i said you know i said you know
what
but see you know i keep wanting to give
up you know
i keep giving up i don't know why i've
always i never i never fire keep giving
up
you know what i just i keep giving up i
don't bring up bringing off
running north story short i met this
lady you know his lady fellas she was 27
years old i'm 56 years of 20 she was 27
years old
she's about to fire they had to ask why
it's a leaking continental i mean she
was fine on me she was fine you know
when she was
you know and then she didn't have
anywhere to stay she came out of south
now south i don't stay in my place the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
she put up i was so i was very nice to
her i was very nicer
and uh she said well i don't really want
a boyfriend you told me i said fine so
well god said maybe
i still got herself maybe i could help
somebody to get me out of me
and it was working i didn't drive she
didn't ring she so i didn't i saw i
swear i just she didn't drink
but looking at her fat ass laying on
that flow i was wanting to get i don't
get in that ass she had another one that
i told her i said look
i know i told but i'm real nice to you
you know i said but
you know it's getting to me you know i
know you young for you like daughter of
me i said but you
you you laying down on my damn floor i
kept saying i kept saying get in the bag
in the back again
they got [ __ ] and she's gotten better if
she would have gotten better i know how
to take the boat i know she
had to give me support but she would not
get in that [ __ ] bed this isn't cold
she got on the floor
you know so she left for [ __ ] in my
house so i'm down at the at the mission
getting some knee
and i was you know i just i just i
wanted i wanna i'm such a i'm such a
[ __ ] like i couldn't just tell her
you know get your stuff and get your
stuff out of my house because she was
stuck she started using me started
seeing how nice i was
and the [ __ ] [ __ ] started using me
so she had all this [ __ ] in my corner
and i saw some bugs coming out
but i don't want she's bringing bugs in
my house i said well next time i see her
i'm gonna let her know she's gotta get
her [ __ ] she'll get the [ __ ] out so she
came over the next time i was supe i'll
push it out again
okay we're good let me give you
something i didn't get rid of two hours
and know i'm the big [ __ ] [ __ ] and
i'm kind of thinking how am i going to
get the girl out of my house
well she i find i told another man and
said you can't stay here no more so she
left but she left herself there
and she come every couple of days and
one day she came over there and
i had a girl in a room with a small
crack and she's downstairs and i made
her weight outside she can understand
why i made it went outside why are you
going to get my [ __ ]
so i said wait a minute this [ __ ] is
something that's blocked and she's
blocking my [ __ ] and she didn't even
give me no [ __ ] so i let her come up
she saw the girl there and they
explained words and she took care of
herself
but anyone was trying to figure out how
to get her out of there and then the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i saw i was going down to get some music
mission and she passed me by she said oh
me and you're gonna have to
you know you know how they get fellas oh
[ __ ] me you're gonna have
issues that's all and i and i
and i was saying i was it was one of
those days this couple of days
when mr lewis don't want to be [ __ ]
with i don't want nobody saying to me
it ain't personal don't say them to me
don't look at me
especially don't say don't say don't
come at me sideways
and i told her i told us i'm a nice guy
i said but i will flip on your ass i
will flip on your ass and i'll go i'll
go straight the opposite way i said
don't don't push me don't don't don't
call me sideways and we'll be cool
you ain't my girlfriend we ain't [ __ ]
so don't don't
so when she saw me that day i i didn't
want to see her at all i didn't want to
see her [ __ ] ass at all i just anyway
and that was personal because her [ __ ]
was in my house that was personal so
when she saw me
she said oh man you're gonna have issues
about my stuff and i can't get my stuff
you know in the background
and i looked at her and i just passed
through by cause i know me i said let me
pass the [ __ ] on back us i'm gonna go
off on the [ __ ]
so when i got around to where the line
was she slid a little black ass around
there
and then some guy was the guy was was
getting on my case about taking cuts to
some other guy was getting on my case
about
about her me my ass being his face and
then
she came around the front of me and said
don't trip out what i said i was just
playing and i went
i'll laugh [ __ ] i said check this out
[ __ ] i said your shit's in my
[ __ ] house
my [ __ ] isn't your [ __ ] house
so how the [ __ ] you have an issue with
me [ __ ] i got an issue with you
that [ __ ] took wait she she had
a water bottle
had a shadow she had a 40 ounce water
bottle
she i never i've never in my life had a
woman talk that woman cussed me out and
called me every kind of [ __ ]
took that water bottle she told me she's
bipolar i should listened
she took that [ __ ] water about she
hit me inside the head with that
[ __ ]
when she hit me with the water the
bottom went one way and the bottom of
the other way and my head went this way
i'm standing there in front of mention
everybody sees this [ __ ]
now normal on a normal plane mr bank i
wanted to grab that [ __ ] about her neck
and beat the holy [ __ ] shuttle over
but i knew where i was at there's too
many lapd out there
and for some reason i hadn't had a drink
i hadn't been drinking so i hadn't got
thank god [ __ ] i had a drink i'd
right then the [ __ ] and with a
dead [ __ ] you know how to beat
her [ __ ]
i would have beat that [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'd have beat that [ __ ] [ __ ] down
[ __ ] [ __ ] i don't [ __ ] dare she
[ __ ] talk to me like that
so i told her i said check this i said
check this out i'm going to walk to my
house
and your ass better walk behind me
because i'm going to have your [ __ ] all
over downtown if you don't get your
so she's walking behind me and she's
cussing me out that's what she said this
is what gets me
she's ah you got up in my face i hit you
with the water bottle cause you made
like you i thought you was going you was
gonna hit me
so you didn't talk [ __ ] to the guys like
that you talk [ __ ] to me you a [ __ ] you
talk [ __ ] to me but you didn't talk to
this guy the thing was i wasn't mad at
the [ __ ] guys i was mad at her
because she was the one who had the [ __ ]
in my house and i was pissed off at her
always but because of my
self-esteem issues she kind of hit she
kind of struck a nerve when the [ __ ]
told me that [ __ ] because
she she got me thinking damn well did i
punk out with them
guys but no no i didn't [ __ ] with
them guys i wouldn't they didn't make me
mad they were just they they they put
salt on the [ __ ] i was already mad at so
when she came around with her ugly ass
and said something smart to me i just
blew up on so she went i mean but she
cursed me out
all the way until i got to them in front
of my place and all my people in front
of my house they're all sitting outside
in front of my house
and she's cussing me cussing me custody
and let me let me let me tell you how i
whoop this [ __ ] ass
i went upstairs got all her [ __ ]
now we we got we they got they got my
door when you get in my door and then
they got
they got it they got a guard [ __ ] every
now and then there's a guard that this
particular day the security guard was i
was like yes
because i didn't know whether this lady
was gonna try to fight me whether she's
gonna try to stab me i know she carried
a big knife
but she was she was when she was coming
after me dude she was threatening me
like
she wanted to kill me i mean she was a
she was a real she was a real
[ __ ] [ __ ] she was a [ __ ] so she come
from somewhere in maryland baltimore
manor with
what he anyway so so she she i
i came downstairs with a shitty security
i said i and i had and i put a [ __ ] in
front of scared i said bam
cannon with the first bag now she now
says i can hear it down says talk
i was just playing when i said what he
said i don't know why he got so mad you
goddamn [ __ ] well
you know she was going on going like
this and when i the last one i went to
the second time i come down the [ __ ]
stairs
i had all this [ __ ] my [ __ ]
hand and i threw it around i
let me i threw it on the ground said bam
that's all of it
and she goes i'm sorry i apologize
i didn't say one [ __ ] word i took my
ass upside wouldn't win in my room
and i was and i and i remember i
remember because i'm a pisces
when i get that [ __ ] mad get the [ __ ]
out of my way you don't tell her what i
do thank god i was in front of that
missing with him in front of that
mission how to beat that [ __ ]
i'll probably try to kill that [ __ ] i
fight a beat in the depth right in the
middle
of that [ __ ] man so i'm pacing the
[ __ ] little patient [ __ ]
face in the [ __ ] room i mad as a
[ __ ] like nobody talked to
i thought about calling my mom then i
couldn't get high so i had my head
that's so oh i'm gonna say this and then
i'm humble because i'm talking about
let me tell y'all let me get out let me
give y'all some real real something i
did that's really really stupid
now i'm talking to i'm talking to the
crack addicts because if you did some
[ __ ] like this
you ain't the only one i got a stimulus
check
and i told myself i'm not gonna [ __ ]
that stimulus take off and god damn
ain't no crack ain't no alcohol ain't
none in the world won't make me [ __ ] off
my stimulation
i had 600 i put half of it on the rent i
had 200
left so i said now i'm not going i'm
gonna go i'm gonna go buy me
a bass guitar i went and bought the most
beautiful
[ __ ] bass guitar
and i had that [ __ ] bass for three
days
i couldn't get the damn thing the tools
you had to fine-tune for something i
couldn't get that somebody's tune
i got high and stolen for a forty dollar
rocker cocaine
and that bass when i went when i got
that bass guitar it was
that was the furthest theme from my mind
because i've been one more for so long
i've had i've gate i've had three i've
been getting to the points i've played a
long time
but just now i said when i get my base
to talk i have something to do
to keep my mind being idle you know
every time i sit and i pick that [ __ ]
base up and i'm playing that [ __ ]
baby
when i took a hit i said i said i i
didn't i i'm going to take a hit but i'm
not going
the first thing i did when i took it i
ran out of money and i sold that goddamn
base star for
2 20. i mean if i saw that damn thing
for 20 out for 29 i thought two and i
guitar
for 29 with cocaine yes and for about a
week i wouldn't come out my room
i was so goddamn i said damn i did that
[ __ ] again
so if your own cocaine man you get
hooked on that [ __ ] if you sell all your
i remember somebody told me one time
they said if
once you get sober once you take it you
might as well sell all your [ __ ] first
don't take it here first sell all your
[ __ ] show your cars or your base star
show your shoes your watches your wings
your coats all yours laundry coats all
your
all your [ __ ] and then take it cause
once you take it
once i take a [ __ ] hit i don't
know what
once i exhale once i
oh [ __ ] off i don't know what the [ __ ]
i'm gonna do
but then god this birthday i'm not gonna
handle money for that kind of [ __ ] cuz i
gotta pay my rent
and i'm so glad i could talk to you guys
again i hope i helped somebody with some
of my [ __ ] to me it's all [ __ ]
but it's all the truth
and uh i don't feel like they can arrive
i don't know i came here today i really
didn't feel like talking
it took me how long enough just to get
out i got that house and start walking
i came down here and saw the car outside
i said this man gets mad sometimes
even though he want to cut somebody's
[ __ ] hide so i came down the
street
went halfway down and look he looked out
the window he looked like a clown i said
oh [ __ ] i better keep on walking he may
turn me away
he said no no man i can use your own
today so i'm glad
that i appreciate you and i'm glad y'all
could listen to me and i'll see you next
time